[MUSIC]
JONATHAN ROCHELLE: Thanks for
coming to the Jamboard session.
If you didn't intend to come
to the Jamboard session,
this flight is on
its way to Detroit.
If you didn't intend
on going to Detroit,
please exit the plane now.
So if you know something
about Jamboard, that's great.
Hopefully you'll learn
a little bit more today.
And if you don't know anything,
you'll start from the start.
I just want to give
you a quick intro.
My name is Jonathan Rochelle.
A long time ago, actually
more than a decade,
I worked on Google Docs
when we launched it.
And our goal there was to reduce
the friction of productivity
for teams and to have people
stop sending attachments
back and forth.
That was one of the main
things that we were going for.
And when we launched
Doc Sheets and Slides,
the one or two things we
actually lamented, I think,
is one, that we were in that
personal productivity zone--
documents, spreadsheets,
and presentations--
because it was familiar.
It's what everybody thought of.
But we were not
that happy that we
didn't have something
else, in terms of format.
Something that was free-form.
Because we know
productivity, it's great.
Once you know what
you want to do,
you can start a document,
start a presentation,
or a spreadsheet.
But if you don't, and you're
just working on ideas,
you need something free-form.
And so, we didn't have
anything at the time.
And the other thing
we lamented was
that we weren't really
giving people tools when
they were collaborating the
most, which was in meetings.
And so, many years
later, we started
a project that was based on
collaboration in free-form.
And the whiteboard was the
thing staring at us, literally,
from the wall, saying
please, fix me.
And two people on the team
actually took this on.
Started off as, I'll call
it a hackathon project.
TJ Varghese, who's here
with me, and Barine Tee,
who is here somewhere
that-- there's Barine.
He'll be up here as well--
and they did
basically a tablet app
that was a real-time
collaboration
on a virtual
whiteboard on tablets.
And while that was great, it
really wasn't great enough.
It felt like, yeah, but
the whiteboard on the wall
is where this really should be.
And so we started working
on hardware with that
and decided that
we really should
go after this on a hardware
and software, fully
grouped appliance product.
A device that could be a
whiteboard in the Cloud
that works like Google
Docs, but in free-form.
And so that's what the team did.
And we went after Jamboard.
We announced it in October,
and we're showing it more now.
And we announced this
morning, general availability
will be in May,
or at least we'll
start taking orders in May.
And so, that's super
exciting for the team.
Once we get to, OK, we have a
product, and you can use it.
The other thing
that's super hard
is actually bringing
it to market.
So I also want to introduce
Lucy Bourne, who's
going to help as well,
do some of the demos.
Who has really taken that
on to help with how do we
get this thing out there.
And she's worked
with some customers
that have been early adopters.
And they've been
using the board,
and we get some good feedback
and some critical feedback
to help us fix things.
And that's where
we're at right now.
So I want to hand
it over to the team.
They're going to give a demo.
They're going to actually
answer questions at the end.
So hopefully you'll enjoy this.
TJ Varghese, Barine
Tee and Lucy Bourne.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TJ VARGHESE: Thanks, JR.
TJ VARGHESE: Thanks, everyone.
And if you guys at the
back want to come forward,
I'm sure you'll have a
lot more to see up front.
So this session,
we're actually going
to give you tips of
how to use the Jamboard
and how to enhance
your brainstorming.
But to get started,
before all of that,
I want to take you
back a little bit.
Sorry, I need to move
to the next slide.
Sorry.
So, as JR mentioned,
we started working
on this quite some time ago.
And at Google, as you guys
know, we love technology, right?
And you probably do too.
And what's great about
technology is it changes
our lives for the better, right?
I mean, I could pull
out my phone right now
and literally pull
up my thermostat.
I live in New York
City, and I can
change the temperature of my
apartment in New York City,
right now.
And that's just amazing.
So tech is also
transforming our workplace.
We've made it easier
to get into a meeting.
You saw that today
with Google Meet.
We make sharing information
a lot more easier.
You can share files
with Google Drive.
And we have a lot of
apps that help us--
enable us to do so
much more, and so much
more efficiently, at work.
And that's something that's
just continually happening.
And at Google, we're
passionate about innovating
in the enterprise
and collaboration
in the enterprise.
And so while we're
focused on innovation,
we take a thoughtful approach
that not only is just
about innovating in
tech but innovating
in a way that actually
makes us better,
makes us perform better.
So take David Sax's quote from,
"The Revenge of the Analog."
He says, "The process of
technological innovation
isn't a story of slow march
from good to better to best.
It's a series of trials that
helps us understand who we are
and how we operate."
So when it comes to
meetings and collaboration,
our team is focused on making
things so much more better.
But better in the
context of how we operate
and how we work today.
A lot of times in
meetings, you're
trying to communicate
information.
And yes, while we've
enabled video conferencing,
sometimes it's
really hard for you
to communicate and
express your idea freely.
And it's very hard
to brainstorm,
especially when you want
to walk to the whiteboard.
So this is pretty essential.
A lot of times we
communicate, as humans,
in a very, very expressive way.
And that sometimes gets
lost in translation
when you're on the phone
or on a video call.
So take, for example,
the whiteboard.
This is so basic,
and yet so powerful.
A lot of times when you have to
make important decisions or you
need to brainstorm
with someone, you
have to be present in the room.
It's a blank canvas.
And what's great about
a canvas is it's open
and you can fill it with
anything that you want.
So, as we talk
about the benefits
of being able to
communicate and express
with each other in meetings,
sometimes technology
is limiting.
And this is something that
we took to heart when we
were thinking about Jamboard.
We looked at other
digital whiteboards.
And we felt that they had
quite a few things that
didn't really quite help
you get better, right?
So for example, some of the
screens were not high fidelity.
They felt like you were
writing, and you couldn't really
see it too well, or
there was a visible lag.
Sometimes when you write, and
as you're drawing and writing,
you started to see that
the ink print, like a half
a centimeter away or
half an inch away.
And sometimes that
really bothered people
when they were trying to
just get their ideas out
of their head.
And so a lot of times, people
would stop using those tools
and just pick up a
whiteboard marker
and use the whiteboard
because it's faster.
Your brain can think faster,
and you want your ideas
to flow with it.
In that process we
didn't necessarily--
when we started looking
at designing Jamboard--
we didn't want to make
it look like a black box.
We wanted it to
inspire creativity.
exude collaboration.
And so we'd spent a lot of
time in designing the Jamboard
in a way that it felt
more like furniture
in your workplace, and more fun,
rather than like a television.
The last thing we noticed is
that buying this technology
often was very expensive,
and so we really
spent a lot of time working with
our partners and our vendors,
ensuring that we could come
up with a world class product
but yet, at an affordable price.
So what's ideal is, we
wanted our digital whiteboard
to be intuitive and simple,
just like a whiteboard.
There's something
amazing about just
being able to walk up
to it, pick up a pen,
and start writing.
You'd never want home screens
and all kinds of applications
in your face to decide
what you want to do.
You just want to walk straight
up and get your ideas done.
So that's why we made Jamboard.
It's a whiteboard we imagined
for collaboration in the Cloud.
This is a product that we're
really proud of here at Google.
We've designed this
from the ground up.
Everything from the silicon,
all the way out to the platform,
to the app.
And it's built on collaboration
at its foundation.
We spent a lot of time on
the design, like I mentioned.
One of our key principles
was to keep it simple.
If you could draw or do
something on a whiteboard
faster than you could
on a digital screen,
we said we'd failed.
And you'll notice
here in the demo
just how quick it is
for you to get started.
Drawing is always on.
You can walk up to it
and just start drawing.
And what's amazing is
the technology that we've
put in here allows
for the things
that you're naturally inclined
to do with a whiteboard.
Where you can write with a
stylus, erase with a finger.
Now, once we got the
basics done, of course,
we can't stop there.
We're Google.
So we focused on how we can
make your ideas come to life.
With intelligent features
like handwriting recognition
and shape recognition to help
you express a lot of the ideas
that you put together,
in a much faster way.
Being able to go to the web
and capture content from there,
or grab images.
And of course, you know
sticky notes and stencils.
And then lastly,
we also enabled--
as JR mentioned, we started
actually on mobile devices.
But we've enabled it for tablet
devices and for smartphones,
both for Android and iOS.
And of course, the
meeting doesn't just
end with a whiteboard.
That would be sad, if
all we did was just let
you collaborate and end there.
We allowed you to save your--
all of your Jams
are saved in Drive.
And not only are
they saved in Drive,
but you can bring in
content from Google Drive
into a Jamboard.
We've also integrated with
Hangouts and Google Meet.
So anytime you're in a
video conferencing call,
you can actually present
your Jamboard to it.
All right.
So now it's time for the demo.
Got Barine here on stage
and Lucy down here.
I'm going to hand
it over to Lucy.
LUCY BOURNE: Awesome.
So we get to do the fun part.
I just wanted to
start with the basics
before we jump into the details.
So, I'm going to go through
navigation and frames,
and I'll hand across to
Barine to go through some
of the tools we have.
So as you can see, we have our
screensaver on at the moment.
It's just a single tap
to jump into the Jam.
So we think about all of this
real estate in front of us
here as a frame.
And in a Jam, so we have
a .jam type on Jamboard.
We have multiple
frames within that.
So this is our frame
bar at the top here.
And it allows you to
navigate within your Jam.
And as you can see,
there's a collaborator
who's already in there.
And from the frame
bar we can add frames.
And we can also duplicate
frames as well as delete them.
And reorder, as
well, as we need to.
So one of the coolest
things about our frame bar
is that it loads
small thumbnails
of what's on each frame.
So it's really easy for us
to see what we're working on
and move between those there.
So, Barine's going to
show us some of the tools.
BARINE TEE: Lucy, let's also
talk about presence as well,
too.
So on the frame bar,
you'll also notice
that all of the collaborators
within the document,
or within the Jam, are
seen and are visible.
So you can tell, OK, well
somebody is modifying this one.
I have sales over here and
I have marketing over here,
so I know exactly what's going
on in my document at any given
time.
All right.
So next up--
I've never seen
the slides before,
guys, so this is
going to be exciting.
Next up, we're going to talk
about what, the toolbar.
All right.
So on the toolbar
over here, you'll
see that we built this
palette interface here
to allow you to access
commonly used interfaces-- so
whether it's brush
selection and choosing
from a range of brushes,
from handwriting
to shape recognition, or
just different brush styles.
But the main goal here
was to simplify everything
like TJ said, right?
We didn't want to inundate
the user with tons of options,
tons of width, tons of
sizes, tons of colors.
We kept it simple.
Set up four markers
there, four colors,
simple things you can do.
Also, eraser function, which
is probably not needed anymore
because, like we talked about,
I can quickly come here,
write something, and then
erase with my finger.
Passive stylus, once again.
No batteries, no parings--
just built into the technology.
Color selection, lasso
tools, commonly used--
sort of, in fact, I
will demo the Lasso.
So in whiteboarding, one of the
big things that we do run into
is that we create this
elaborate concept,
and we have databases and
clouds and, probably enough
clouds for the day, maybe.
But we always run out of space.
Well, this enables us
to solve that problem.
I can quickly come in,
grab some bit of content,
and just move it out of the way.
And OK, I forgot to--
in fact, let's just put
another process there
instead of whatever
we were doing.
All right.
And obviously some more
content tools as well--
post-its--
LUCY BOURNE: And we're going
to walk through a few of those
in a moment as well.
And kind of give a
scenario, I think.
BARINE TEE: Absolutely.
All right, guys.
Sorry.
We're having
technical difficulties
here on the monitor.
No slides.
TJ VARGHESE: All right.
So you've seen a little bit
of our content creation,
like we mentioned.
You can just get started
by tapping on the screen,
and it's instant draw, just
like a regular whiteboard.
Next, we'll talk
about how you get
started with a remote meeting.
Like we've said,
there's a lot of times
you're on a call with someone.
LUCY BOURNE: That's great.
So, I'm not sure if any
of you saw in the keynote,
but we have this area which we
call our action draw, which is
where all the action happens.
So, the piece that I wanted to
call out is Present to Meeting.
This allows you to enter
the name of the Hangout
that you want to join.
And it adds the board to
that as a silent participant.
So whether your
collaborators on the Hangout
have the Jam app or the
web browser version,
they're also able to
follow along on the Hangout
and see what you
are adding to this
at any given point in time.
So in terms of the view
that they would see,
it would be the current frame
that you were working on.
I know a lot of you are
thinking, that's great,
I want to be able to--
my collaborators to see
what I'm working on here,
but I also want to see the face
when I'm working with them.
So Barine's going to walk
us through our video call
tool, which we also have
in this action drawer
in the top corner.
BARINE TEE: OK.
So the video call
tool is simple.
It's built on the Hangouts
API, which you just
saw has been revolutionized to
streamline that process there.
But I simply go in,
and all I have to do
is just turn on my video feed.
Now once I turn on my--
turn on my video feed.
So I have my video feed there.
Everybody say cheese, on this
little section over here.
But once I turn
on my video feed,
I can quickly jump
into that call,
and this call is now
hosted within the document.
So anybody there
can also do the same
and then collaborate with
users within the Jam.
TJ VARGHESE: All right.
So our next section
is going to be
talking about working together
better and collaborating.
I think you've already kind of
seen collaboration happening,
but I think you want to talk a
little bit about the avatars.
LUCY BOURNE: So I know Barine
called this out earlier,
but now we have a few
other folks in here.
So we actually have
this avatar here
which shows us there's
another Jamboard working
in the session, on the
stage, off to the side.
We also have [? Tay. ?] So
[? Tay ?] is in this room.
Could you give us a big
wave, [? Tay? ?] Awesome.
So as you can see, he's
on a mobile device.
Could you throw up a
sticky note or content
so we can see your avatar?
Here we go.
So that's [? Tay ?] adding
content here directly
from our companion app.
Our app is for iOS and
for Android, obviously,
and it works for tablet
as well as for phone.
One of the benefits of
having the companion app
is that it's tied
to a user account.
So I want to pause
briefly and just
talk about how we've set up and
designed privacy and security
for content on Jamboards.
So this is considered to be
a shared enterprise device,
and with that in
mind, this actually
operates on an
anonymous account.
What that means is that when you
start a new Jam from the board,
you'll have to add an owner.
So if you add an
owner, that will
allow you to then access
that Jam at a later point
from phone or from
tablet as well.
So we've seen [? Tay ?]
joining from his phone.
TJ, did you have a
tablet up there as well?
TJ VARGHESE: Yep.
I have my tablet up here, and
I'm going to write "Let's jam."
All right.
LUCY BOURNE: Awesome.
TJ VARGHESE: OK.
So now that we've talked
about collaboration,
being able to collaborate
between two boards,
between mobile
devices, let's talk
about how we can enrich your
content to be so much better.
LUCY BOURNE: Great.
So I'm going to lead a small
scenario, pretty much a carbon
copy of what we did
during the keynote
but a little bit shorter.
So we're going to
walk through all
of the different really
content-rich tools
that we have in our
palette off to the side.
So to start with, we're going
to brainstorm some ideas here.
So I'm going to say ideas here
will be for keep versus cut,
and I'm going to ask all
of the collaborators--
so I think we have
[? Ghanesh and ?] [? Tay, ?]
give a big wave out--
in our audience.
We'll have TJ and also Barine.
If you all want to throw
up some post-it ideas.
Let's think about a new
advertising campaign.
Making whiteboards awesome.
I think this is a winning idea.
Jam for tight spaces.
Coffee as a service.
Interesting.
I like the creativity.
OK.
So we have some ideas up there.
I'm going to go with
making whiteboards awesome.
I think this is a winner.
So what we're going to do
is think about some images
that go with that.
So I'm going to open our web
search from the side here.
So you can see we have
the web search at the top.
Before I jump in,
though, I actually
think image search
is best for this.
So image search allows us
to really quickly and easily
access images from the web.
So I'm going put in
here whiteboard--
Jamboard-- and see what we get.
So we have a range of images of
people whiteboarding away here.
Let's throw some of
these in for inspiration.
OK.
So this will be the start
of ideas for our advertising
campaign.
OK, great.
So we've made a start.
And I'm going to,
I think, now go
into Google Drive, because
we're going to need a plan
to bring this to life.
So TJ, I think we
had some planning
slides that you've been
working on earlier.
Could you throw those in?
TJ VARGHESE: Yep.
All right.
So I've just opened Google
Drive from my mobile app,
from the Jam app.
There's a button that you can
open in content from Drive
and you can drop them in here.
LUCY BOURNE: So
I'm going to just
double-tap to open that
object, and as you can see,
this pops out a window.
And what I can see
from here, all of the
slides in this presentation.
I just use one finger
to scroll through,
and I can see all of
the different content
that we've been
working on previously.
So I'm going to
add in a few pieces
from here, into
this presentation.
And then once I'm
done with that,
I can just drag this down to
the trash bar at the bottom.
OK.
So now, as you see, we've
being able to bring in content
to help us with our project
from three separate places.
We have notes.
If you think of what this
looks like traditionally,
we have a huge expanse
of a wall with 55
bits of paper falling off.
Now it's all digital, and
we can share this out easily
once we're done.
We also have content
externally hosted from the web.
I didn't mention this, but
all of the content that
comes from our image
search is copyright safe
to use as part of your workflow,
which is really helpful.
We also have this
piece here, which
is content we've been working
on at a prior point in time.
So this is from a presentation
and pulled in from Drive.
TJ VARGHESE: Perfect.
So now Barine's
going to show us--
BARINE TEE: Intelligent
tools, right?
So, this is obviously what
Google is known for, right?
The whiteboard wouldn't
just be the whiteboard
unless we can actually add
some intelligence to it.
So I'm actually
going to jump in here
and show you some
of our behavior.
I know you've seen this
in some of the videos,
and maybe some of you are
seeing it in our sandbox area,
but you know, let's pick a--
well mostly--
well-known statement.
Now, normally my handwriting
isn't that great,
so let's actually make it
a little bit more difficult
for the Jamboard here.
Good luck.
[LAUGHTER]
BARINE TEE: All right.
Maybe a little bit
too difficult there.
Let's also look at
shape recognition.
So besides that, I might want
to quickly spin up a diagram,
spin up certain graphs or
so, maybe an org chart,
or something like that.
But here I can easily
take these tools
and turn regular
boxes, that now become
movable objects, into
something a little bit better.
Now this one here, I
can never actually get.
And I still can't.
[LAUGHTER]
All right?
TJ VARGHESE: Awesome.
Now that you're seeing a lot
of the tools and capabilities
Jamboard has, like we
said, it's all about where
do you go from here.
So Lucy's going to talk to
us a little bit about how you
can take your ideas with you.
LUCY BOURNE: I'm going to take
you back into action draw here,
and you can see there's
a list of options
and we have a few things
we can do from here.
So the first one I wanted to
mention is sending a copy.
There's a lot of
points in time where
you might want to share
an artifact of what
you've been working on.
This is that
traditional use case
where you might take a
photo of a whiteboard.
But what this
allows you to do now
is to take a digital copy of
the work you've been doing.
So you just need to add
in the email address
of your collaborator, and
this will allow you either
to send a single
frame as a PNG or all
of the frames in
your Jam as a PDF.
We've seen a lot of
early-adopter customers
use that in a number of ways.
One of the most
frequent use cases
is actually adding those
PDFs or PNGs to slide decks
as well so they have a
ready-made image just
to throw up on their slide.
In addition to that
though, you actually
might want to share this out and
have others collaborate on it
with you.
So in terms of doing
that, I talked a little
before about our companion
app for phone and for tablet.
To add collaborators,
you have two options.
The first is, you just
hit share and just like
we did with send the copy, you
add in their email address.
The alternative to
doing that is actually
using our broadcast code tool.
So you can see at
the bottom here
you have the broadcast
code for this Jam
that we're currently on and the
option to join a new broadcast.
That generates a six-digit
alphanumeric code
that you can either enter
into a collaborative device,
like a phone or a tablet,
or onto another Jamboard
to collaborate with others.
Did you want to
talk a little more
about that kind of seamless,
walk-in, walk-out experience?
TJ VARGHESE: Yeah.
So we've also allowed
for your mobile apps
to replace the need for you to
take a photo of a whiteboard.
So you can actually
pull out your phone
and you can find a
board that's nearby.
So if you are in a workplace and
you have two boards in a room,
it will actually tell you that
there is a board near to you,
and you can actually claim
content from your Jam app
on your phone, without
touching the board,
and it will send a
notification to the board.
And anyone who is at
the board can say, OK,
you agree to allow to
give that person a copy.
So, Lucy, you want to
give us a demo of that?
LUCY BOURNE: Sure thing.
So I actually have a
Jam up here that one
of our creative designers
was working on earlier.
And I want to push it
up so you can see some
of the cool stuff he's done.
So I'm in the app on my
phone, and I'm actually
in that active Jam that
I was talking about.
In the top corner we have
a small icon for our board,
and I'm going to do a
search and look for what
boards are close by here.
So I'm going to try
breakout board one.
And what this does is it
allows me to push this Jam up
onto the board.
BARINE TEE: Wrong board, Lucy.
That board.
LUCY BOURNE: So, Barine, well--
BARINE TEE: But as you
can see, Lucy is sort of--
she's taken that same Jam
and she's pushed it on here.
And within a few seconds,
that Jam content that she had
shows up on the board.
So imagine a scenario like
Lucy said-- she's walking out
of a conference room.
She got kicked out
because you know she--
TJ VARGHESE: Ran over time.
BARINE TEE: She goes somewhere
else to another Jamboard,
and just like that she
can continue her session.
TJ VARGHESE: OK.
So for a lot of the
tech enthusiasts,
you're probably wondering, what
does the Jamboard come with?
I'm going to hand it back
to Barine to talk about--
BARINE TEE: What's
actually in this Jamboard?
What's powering this Jamboard?
So I'll quickly
go over to specs.
And I'll go somewhere I
can actually see the specs.
Well to start, the main idea,
just like TJ said earlier,
we want the technology
to disappear.
We want the latencies to
be as low as possible.
This way, it doesn't-- you're
not fighting against yourself
to actually use this device.
But I'll just read
this down here.
It's a 55 inch, 4K, UHD display,
120 Hertz touch scan rate,
60 Hertz video refresh rate.
We've got the wide
angle camera on the top.
This is so you can actually
do a video-to-video call in,
as well as taking
images and adding
the content to the Jamboard.
Down-firing speakers as well.
There's an NFC module built in.
There's also Type-C built
in, so I can actually
charge my laptop,
charge my phone.
I can actually connect
my laptop in there
and use the Jamboard
as a video screen.
It accepts video-in as well
through the Type-C. HDMI 2.0,
it's the 1.4 spec.
USB 3.0 as well, too.
And obviously, one of
the staple features
here is the passive stylus.
Passive stylus, passive eraser.
And the Jamboard will know the
difference between the eraser
and the stylus,
regardless of the fact
that nothing's in here.
LUCY BOURNE: And one
thing I wanted to add,
which we haven't
been able to display
during the last few
days, but the board
can be wall-mounted as
well as stand-mounted.
So in terms of the
use case for a stand,
we've seen it's hugely popular
for things like team breakout
rooms or for collaboration
across different teams
so they can move
it between spaces.
The wall mount is a
really terrific option
for a permanently placed board.
And we've seen teams
do that a lot more with
four-to-six-person meeting
rooms where there's a lot
of collaboration happening.
TJ VARGHESE: And
one last feature
that we didn't put it here on
the slides, because we didn't
necessarily want
you to try it out,
is it has Google
Cast built into it.
So if you ever have
slides or other content
that you want to put here
and use this as a display,
you can with Google Cast.
So, like I said at the start,
we wanted to price it right.
It's going to be available
for purchase in May.
It will be priced at $4,999.
There's a $600 annual
management support fee,
and we are going to be running
a initial promotion at 50% off.
And all of this is going
to get so much better.
Sorry, to clarify, it's 50% of
the annual subscription fee.
Everybody saw that
slide very well.
BARINE TEE: Just for you guys.
[MUSIC]